against the backdrop of the Ukraine
crisis NATO is talking about
intensifying its military presence in
Eastern European member states such as
Poland the Czech Republic and the Baltic
States if you lose I think it is moving
closer to our war and we definitely
don't want that kind of duty it's not a
good idea to fuel it any further it's
been shown them i think western states
are to show that they're there if need
be pleasant sign quinta this fork like
this who is bigger who is stronger
comparison is silly and senseless we
don't have to accept anything forty
percent of Germans believe NATO should
do more to protect Eastern European
member states but a fifty three percent
majority says no seven percent are
undecided yet as Afghan rotten everyone
says the other side started it that's
how all conflicts and wars begin but
we're in an age of diplomacy in which
every possible diplomatic solution
should be considered before taking such
steps so you sure didn't limit Germans
are even more opposed to bundeswehr
involvement with 61 percent rejecting
the idea
you